Thì mừng có thể là hịt sức mạnh đu con đột của trang
Thì là được sống lại những cái ngày tháng lịch sử của tính tộc
Qua thứ? Tốn trọng khắp nghiệp
Nếu tối tương lấy, tuần tạm, tuần tạm, tuần tạm
Cùng ra sức của đấu, xây dựu, lựa, vừa đam, quá bình
Cúng nhập, tạnh phúc, rộm, và phát triển
Cứ đồ người ta ngán đây, rất trường thành
Nhìn nợ, rất trường ta vụ của thuộc và bên dưới
Chúng ta sẽ có trởi cháu là bây giờ
Chó đảo
Chó đảo, dân ra ngoài là mừng được tuần hảo
Vì cũng sống trong cái thời và mình em in thấy
Đoàn dự bình rất là biết hơn
Những thế hệ cho ông tạ, hệ xin tì tục hốc
Chúng ta sẽ không mặt nha.
Vì đây, tôi thấy con Thai đổi không dịt từng gần gặp.
Cảm chúc của nó sẽ trải ra như mắt quân.
Lên là có chơi trong đó có ít nhiều sức máo của xin tôi.
Làm đến lịch sử dụng trên thẳng phá mình là cơm.